Hey everyone, my name is Eric Hanchett.
I am a senior developer advocate at AWS
and I'm going to talk to you about how
you can save on token costs. Now, I'm
going to show you five ways that you can
reduce your token costs while using and
creating agents.
So, the first way you can do that is to
cache your system prompt. Let me show
you some code. Now, I'm using AWS's
Strands agents. This works with all
different providers. This is a little
bit of pseudo code, but the idea is that
you can add cache prompt equals default.
And what that'll do is on the first call
of your agent, it will send the full
system prompt over and then on every
subsequent call, it will have a much
reduced system prompt being sent over.
So, it'll be cached. You can also cache
the tool prompts and messages as well.
This may sound obvious, but you want to
look into routing your different
messages based on the difficulty. So,
here's a code example.
Let's imagine that you have a task
that's very difficult. You may want to
use one of the newer frontier models.
However, if it's something simpler, you
want to use a cheaper model. In this
case, maybe we use Claude Haiku for a
cheap something cheap and then use
Claude Sonnet for something a little bit
more difficult. And then you can use an
if statement. You can even have another
model that's very cheap decide which
model to use. So, you can play around
with this, but I highly recommend don't
use the most expensive model for
everything you're doing. You want to use
multiple different models based on the
use case. And then try to route to it
inside your agent.
Another good tip is to offload the tool
result.
Let me show you some code on here. Once
again, I'm using strands agents. This is
a a manual way to do it. There is some
additional APIs that the strands agents
offers to do this.
If you have a large tool result that's
coming back, you can store it locally or
in the cloud and then use some kind of
summarization that saves on tokens. So
that way when it's being called over and
over again, the tool result isn't added
into the context every time every time
the tool loops or every time the agent
loops. So if you can find any way that
where you have this tool result that you
don't necessarily send it on every
single call back to the large language
model, that will save a lot of tokens
for you. And like I said, there's a few
APIs to do this, but it essentially you
can do the summarization technique.
You can also cap your tool loops.
So when you're dealing with the agent
loop and it decides to do a tool call,
I've had this happen often where it
calls the tool over and over and over
again. And if you don't cap that tool
call, then it might run 10, 20 times. It
might get into an infinite loop, which
would be very bad for your token usage.
So always set a max iterations of how
many times it will loop. A good thing
you can do before you deploy your agent
is to run some observability tools and
take a look at the tool call use for
every single tool and then see how long
each one of them is running and how many
times they're looping. And that way you
can get an idea of how efficient the
tool call is.
Last but not least, we can trim the
history.
So if we're using a multi-turn agent and
we are talking back and forth, you will
find at times that the conversation
history will get very large on every
single call, that whole conversation
history will be sent back to the large
language model. And this can eat through
hundreds, if not thousands, of tokens.
In Strand's agents, we have something
called sliding window conversation
manager, which which this does is it
looks back at the last 10 messages and
only sends those back. And you can set
this to whatever you want. And that way
you're not sending these huge message
histories back to the agent every single
time a new message comes in. The
downfall of this, or the trade-off of
this, I should say, is that you will
lose the message history from the
beginning. The way you want to deal with
that is you can use uh some sort of
summarization of the history and then
put that into the context window. So,
rather than sending all of it, you may
send a small amount once you hit this
sliding window.
Uh this will save you a lot of tokens.
So, in conclusion, we have five things.
Cache the system prompt.
And if you can, maybe the tool prompt
and messages. Route by difficulty. Don't
use the same expensive model for
everything you're doing, for every
single task. Offload these big tool
results. So, if you have a large tool
result, you can summarize it and not
have it being sent in the agent loop and
overloading your context. You can cap
those tool loops. Make sure you use
observability tools to see how long tool
calls are taking and how many loops
they're they're doing and and then try
to iterate over that. And then, of
course, trim the history if you're using
a multi-turn conversation with your
agent, so that way the whole
conversation isn't being sent over and
over again for very long conversations.
Thank you for listening to my very
quick, almost lightning talk today. If
you like to go deeper, find me on
LinkedIn at Eric Hanchett. I also blog
at programwitheric.com.
And then you can find me on social media
at EricCH. Love to talk to you guys
more. Thanks.